[Music]  new at noon a new look for one of the  las vegas strip's oldest properties  we're talking about circus circus and  look at that it has a new pool and  they've also doubled occupancy at the  pool to 400 looks like there's plenty of  space  for that the modern design gives the  pool a new look staff say it's more  enticing  anything we add to the property that  especially if guests have been coming  here for a long time they love to see  that we're working on it  and a family in the summer is going to  want to go to the pool so this is a  great option for guests this summer  the renovation there also includes more  deck space and a splash zone for all the  children there good fun